hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast i am sitting today with matthias
desmond who is a professor of clinical
psychology at ghent university he also
holds a master's degree in statistics
professor desmond welcome to dark horse
uh thank you brett it's a pleasure to be
here
excellent well i am pretty excited about
this conversation i have been
steeped in your work not for very long
but
i have looked carefully at it and i have
found a tremendous amount that resonates
for me
there is one element that i think
um
i don't know that i would say that i
differ with you on it but there is a way
in which when a psychological
perspective and an evolutionary
perspective
meet there is a lot of potential
gain to be had if we can figure out how
the two stories intersect but that's not
always an easy process i'm hoping it
will happen here
but i think to begin with it would make
sense you have
erupted into the
public eye
for your work on what is called mass
formation
some will have heard it discussed as
mass formation psychosis but i don't
think that's the general term
so what i would like is for you to
describe the process of mass formation
and what it has to do with certain
patterns of history that everybody who
watches this will already be familiar
with even if they don't realize that
they are in fact patterns
yes yes indeed i never used the term
mass formation psychosis because i think
bro from an intellectual
and an ethical point of view and even a
strategical point of view it is better
to use the term mass formation which is
more neutral term less stigmatizing
which doesn't enter the domain of
individual psychodiagnostics and so on
so i prefer the term mass formation
excellent i think that's right the one
downside to it is that um it does not
immediately call anything to mind for
most people
psychosis obviously does but i agree
with you psychosis is uh prejudicial and
counterproductive our first sponsor for
this week's episode is vevo barefoot
shoes made for feet most shoes are made
for someone's idea of what feet should
be and be constrained by vivos are made
by people who know feet and know how to
use them here at dark horse we love
these shoes they are beyond comfortable
the tactile feedback from the surfaces
you are walking on is amazing and they
cause no pain at all because there are
no pressure points forcing your feet
into odd positions they're fantastic
our feet are the product of millions of
years of evolution humans evolve to walk
move and run barefoot but modern shoes
that are overly cushioned and strangely
shaped have negatively impacted foot
function and are contributing to a
health crisis one in which people move
less than they might in part because
their shoes make their feet hurt
vivo barefoot shoes are designed wide to
provide natural stability thin to enable
you to feel more and flexible to help
you build your natural strength from the
ground up
foot strength increases by sixty percent
in a matter of months just by walking
around in them
the number of people wearing vevo
barefoots is growing once people start
wearing these shoes they don't seem to
stop
vivo barefoot has a great range of
footwear for kids and adults and for
every activity except wing walking from
hiking and training to everyday wear
vivo has got your next pair of shoes
they're a certified b-corp pioneering
regenerative business principles and
their footwear is produced using
sustainably sourced natural and recycled
materials with the aim to protect the
natural world so you can run wild on it
go to vivobarefoot.com
darkhorse to get an exclusive offer of
20 off
additionally all new customers get a
hundred day trial so you can see if you
love them as much as we do that's v i v
o b a r e f o o t dot com slash dark
horse
our next sponsor for this episode is
moink that's moo plus oink
an 8th generation farmer founded mike
and is working hard to help save the
family farm and get its customers access
to the highest quality meat on earth or
anywhere else in the known universe
whereas 97 percent of the chickens
served in the u.s are dipped in chlorine
solution moink a family farm will never
do that
moint delivers grass-fed and
grass-finished beef and lamb pastured
pork and chicken and wild-caught alaskan
salmon direct to your door
monk farmers farm like your grandparents
did
and as a result monk meat tastes like it
should which is to say delicious
unlike the supermarket moic gives you
total control over the quality and
source of your food you can choose the
meat delivered in every box from rib
eyes to chicken breasts to pork chops to
salmon fillets and much more
plus you can cancel at any time
we love everything about moiq the fact
that the meat is grass-fed and finished
on small farms the lovely publications
that come along with it and of course
the meat itself
shark tank host kevin o'leary called
moint bacon the best bacon he'd ever
tasted i agree it's amazing
keep american farming going by signing
up at moicbox.com darkhorse and
listeners of this show will receive free
filet mignon for a year
that's one year of the best filet mignon
you'll ever taste but for a limited time
it's spelled moic m o i n k box dot com
slash dark horse moinkbox.com
slash darkhorse
this process of mass formation is a
it's a specific kind of group formation
which has very specific effects at the
level of individual mental functioning
for instance if people are in the grip
of a process of mass formation
they tend to become radically blind for
everything that goes against the
narrative the group believes in it is as
if they don't have any capacity anymore
to take a critical distance of what the
group believes in and this holds even
for people who are extremely intelligent
and and and highly educated so that's
that's one of the of the strangest
things of mass formation
um even the higher the level of
education it has been observed time and
time again the more vulnerable people
become for mass formation which is quite
strange of course
then a second characteristic a very
important uh
characteristic of mass formation is that
as people are in the grip of it they
typically become
willing to self-sacrifice it is as if
they are no longer aware of their own
individual interests as if they are
willing to sacrifice everything for the
sake of the collective interests and to
a very extreme extent
and a third
uh crucial phenomenological
characteristic of mass formation is that
people who are in the grip of it
typically become radically intolerant
for dissonant voices and in the end this
goes quite far in the end
people who are in the grip of mass
formation that
typically start to commit cruelties and
atrocities towards the people that do
not go along with the masses
and
even more specific they do so
as if it is an ethical duty to do so
that's typical for for for masses of all
times whether we are talking about the
crusades or the victims or the french
revolution or the emergence of the
masses
in the soviet union or in nazi germany
every time you see the same
characteristic
after a while when the mass formation
becomes very deep
uh people typically start to commit
cruelties towards those who do not go
along with them and they do so as
evangelical as if there's an ethical
duty to give only one example
two months ago i was talking with this
woman of iran and this conversation this
conversation is available on the
internet who lived in iran during the
revolution in 1979 which was the
beginning of a large-scale process of
mass formation in iran
and
she described how she had seen with her
own eyes how a mother reported her son
to the state and how she hung the rope
and now around his neck when he was on
the scaffold and how she claimed to be a
heroine for doing so that's that's a
process that
um the typical end point of mass
formation is that in a strange way
people are willing to commit cruelties
towards everyone who doesn't go wrong
with the masses and they do so
as if it is an ethical duty to do so
all right so that's that's that's purely
the phenomenological characteristics of
mass formation but
as soon as you i think
that shows how extremely important it is
well let's uh let's pause there for a
second i want you to complete describing
the model i think it's very important
that you get the whole thing on the
table but i want to point out that what
you've described so far
is a series of paradoxes where things
that do not appear to make sense
become
apparent driving forces of important
historical processes and what i hope we
will get to
is an explanation for why those things
are in fact not paradoxical why they
make sense in an evolutionary context
even though they seem utterly absurd to
an observer
you will try to we will try to at least
i can describe the mechanism of mass
formation that's what i did in my book
the psychology of authoritarianism which
was recently published i i go into the
mechanism the psychological mechanism
and i'm very curious to your
ideas about the biological mechanisms of
mass formation but i go into the
psychological mechanisms of mechanisms
of mass formation in order to show
actually that these strange utterly
seemingly utterly absurd characteristics
at the phenomenological level can be
explained in a psychological way and
start to make sense
um
and maybe well it's important to to
to to to stipulate from the beginning
that mass formation exists as long as
mankind exists it exists uh
as long as mankind exists but the modern
masses um are not the same as the
ancient masses there are very important
differences very important differences
that um uh
are crucial from a psychological
perspective for instance
the ancient masses were masses that
gathered physically they gathered
physically the individuals that
constituted the mass
were
physically present or were physically
together and the modern masses are what
is sometimes called what are sometimes
called lonely masses modern masses are
very often created through the mass
media
modern masses or groups of people that
all share the same ids that are all in
the grip of the same images that are on
the grip of the same narratives and
myths but that never physically gathered
that often live in a rather isolated
state and that is exactly it is exactly
this state
of individuals in a lonely mass what
makes them extremely susceptible and
extremely vulnerable for all kinds of
propaganda
that's that's that's it's a perfect
state in which you can reach someone
with propaganda and take in the group of
propaganda so that's an important thing
and
as soon as you start to understand that
the phenomenon of mass formation
is the basis of what we call
totalitarian states you start to
understand how extremely important it is
to understand what mass formation is and
how it works and also why it's only the
mechanism of mass formation that allows
us to explain
why totalitarian states emerged for the
first time in the 20th century before
the 20th century there were classical
dictatorships but there were no
totalitarian states and the difference
between a classical dictatorship in a
totalitarian state is exactly at a
psychological level
that the totalitarian state is based on
mass formation on the emergence of a
mass or a crowd
which led by certain leaders can cease
control of society while a classical
dictatorship is very primitive in its
psychological mechanism in a classical
dictatorship the population is just
scared of a small group of the
aggressive potential of a small group
and accepts therefore that the small
group imposes its
social contract unilaterally in a
totally different state is based on a
completely different psychological
prince
process namely the process of mass
formation
um is it okay but if i if i just in a
concise way in a nutshell describe the
process of mass emission the mechanism
yep uh before you do though i just want
to highlight something that you said
there about the difference between this
process in ancient masses versus modern
masses and point out that what you're
really
describing
is the perfect storm that emerged in
covid
where people who were literally
confined to their homes more than they
had ever been before had intense
opinions about people they had never met
would never meet they had opinions about
technologies that they did not
understand
um in fact some of the you know the few
excursions that they made were to source
these technologies that had biological
implications they couldn't hope to
fathom
and so there is something about this
modern technological moment reflected of
course in the conversation that you and
i are having we're having a face-to-face
conversation thousands of miles apart
and so those kinds of technologies
i would argue have simply interfaced
with this apparently ancient mechanism
and they have actually facilitated
and amplified its power in a modern
context in a way that
uh presumably nobody understood was
likely
absolutely
all right so you were going to describe
it i couldn't agree more that the
situation was the perfect
situation uh for people to to to
to get in the grip off of this process
of mass formation and and in the grip of
a narrative that does that was
distributed through the through the mask
yes and
uh you know
the audience of this podcast will be
highly non-random and they will be
people overwhelmingly who have over the
course of the last couple of years
had
a large number of interactions where
people that they thought they knew
appear to believe
perfectly bizarre things and to be
immune
to the detection that those things are
not supported by the evidence it's it's
the most remarkable experience to look
someone you know well in the eye
and to not be able to understand how
they could possibly believe the things
that they seem to
um so anyway that's that's what we're
discussing here
and i think the next thing you were
going to do is you were going to
describe
um the characteristics uh that you that
lead to to mass formation is that right
yes yes yes yes that would be good i
think yes yes so mass formation is this
very strange kind of group formation
emerges when when
large-scale mass formation mass
formation emerges in a society when when
the population is in a very specific
mental condition
and the first and most crucial
characteristic of this condition is that
many people have to feel disconnected
from their natural and social
environment that's the most crucial
condition many people have to feel
lonely disconnected from the natural and
social environment and that was
something that was very clear just
before the corona crisis worldwide
over 30 of the people worldwide claimed
not to have one meaningful relationship
and to only connect to other people
through the internet so it was a very
strange situation and the number of
people feeling lonely and disconnected
was
increasing
throughout the last few hundred years
and that also explains why throughout
the last few hundred years the mass
formation actually became ever stronger
and and in the end the masses became so
strong
that they could seize control of society
and create a new kind of of state system
namely the total italian state that was
something that was anticipated
by gustav lebowen
in in
1895 already he warned the world then
that mass formation became increasingly
strong and he said if we continue like
this the masses will seize control over
society led by certain leaders and that
was exactly what happened about 20 years
later gustaf lebon describes this
in his book the psychology of the crowd
so but in the most crucial condition
preconditioned for mass formation uh to
emerge on a large scale in society as
always
that uh
there's a number of there is a high
number of uh uh socially disconnected uh
isolated people disconnected people and
uh okay so that's your first
characteristic
when you argue that this became
especially prominent as a precondition
at the beginning of the 20th century
is this because people were moving away
from their natal homes to work is it is
connected to the industrial revolution
or what caused that extra disconnection
it's definitely connected to the
industrial revolution definitely because
it's clear even you can see in two ways
there is that the level of loneliness is
connected to the level of
industrialization and technology use if
you look
at this moment in the world that you
will see that the problem of loneliness
is almost perfectly correlated to the
level of industrialization and
technology used in the world for
instance in northern america and western
europe you will see that the levels of
loneliness are much higher than
elsewhere in the united in the in the
united kingdom theresa may appointed a
minister of loneliness in 2017 just
because she realized how she
acknowledged the the number of people
who felt lonely and also in the in the
us
the u.s surgeon
mentioned that there was a loneliness
epidemic so it's generally accepted that
the problem is connected to
industrialization and technology use and
you also see throughout the ages that as
the level of industrialization increases
and as the level of technology use
increases we also see this
increase
in
the number of people who feel lonely uh
so it's definitely connected to each
other okay all right so your first
characteristic is the disconnectedness
and loneliness of people
what's the second
yes and then from the first one follows
the second one which is that
many people
have to experience a lack of meaning
making in life
but the two are are inevitably connected
because
as
the social bond between people
impoverishes or deteriorates
and you will automatically see that
people start to be confronted with lack
of meaning making and that's just
because people are intrinsically
human uh social animals and and social
beings and that
they experience meaning every time they
see
that their existence has an effect on
the other
if people notice that their existence
has an effect on the other then they
will spontaneously experience
uh
meaning and purpose in life and this
this if this connection if the social
bonds deteriorates then
in the same way the experiences of
meaning making will drop away from
existence and people often don't connect
the two to each other but they are
connected psychologically
they are very strongly connected at the
psychological level
and also if you if you could if you look
at the number of people reporting that
they considered a job [ __ ] job
uh um uh at the end of uh
uh of somewhere in 2000 2018 there was
this gallup world poll which indicated
that 60 of the people worldwide
considered their job to be a so-called
[ __ ] job which is only logical
because if people make something if they
produce something with their work they
almost never
know the person who will use what they
produce meaning that they never see the
effect
of their own labor of their own
work on the other and that's probably
one of the reasons why so many people
have the experience that their job is a
blue shirt
yeah this is a really important fact and
of course before kovid and and
before the woke revolution many had
noticed the collapse of our capacity to
make meaning which i also take to be
i mean there's a lot to discuss and
maybe we'll come back to it but
the fact of people
largely partnering with other people
that they don't grow up with that they
don't know especially well that our
adult lives are interfacing with a lot
of people we may like them but we don't
know them means that our language is
impoverished because
we don't know the very precise meaning
of a term as somebody else uses it we
just sort of have the general you know
english version in my case
um and so that bluntness of every
every term we might wish to use means
that the highest quality meaning we
could possibly make is pretty low right
it's just a bunch of dull tools in the
shed and you can't make a fine piece of
furniture with them
but anyway i i interrupted you so you
have disconnection and loneliness is the
first characteristics uh a failure of
meaning making as the second
characteristic
what's third yes
uh as soon as people start to to be
to exist in a disconnected state
confront and confronted with a
lack of meaning making in life
something very specific happens at the
effective level
in that
condition people typically start to
experience so so-called free-floating
anxiety frustration and aggression that
means all kinds of negative effects that
are not connected to a mental
representation
or
in plain terms just people feel anxious
frustrated and aggressive without
knowing what they feel anxious
frustrated and aggressive for all their
anxiety and negative effectivity is
disconnected from the environment and
fundamental representations and that is
an extremely aversive mental state
because if you feel for instance anxious
and you don't know what you feel anxious
for you will typically feel completely
out of control just because you cannot
protect yourself from something you
don't know and in the same way if you
feel a lot of frustration and aggression
but you don't know what you feel
frustrated and aggressive for
you
there is no way you can direct your
frustration and aggression at something
in the outer world so it remains in
yourself and that that is this condition
this
statement of disconnectedness the state
of lack of meaning making this all this
free-floating negative effectivity
um
that is the the
if if a population is in this mental
condition then it's ready it's pretty
it's ready for for large scale mass
formation
and something yeah
well uh so free-floating anxiety and i
know uh from reading your work
that what you mean is that it doesn't
it's not about something concrete
and you you point out here that people
have a general sense of foreboding
and that that um
is particularly
frustrating let's say because it doesn't
suggest a proper course of action right
no exactly
usually this leads to the development of
individual psychological symptoms
like a phobia or
uh one or another obsessional
obsessional behavior
is typically one way in which all this
free-floating anxiety can be connected
symptomatically to a certain
representation
and this allows a subject
to have a minimal level of control over
its anxiety because
when you feel anxious but you have no
idea what you feel anxious for you're
completely out of control but if you can
symptomatically connect your anxiety to
for instance a spider or a snake
then
you have
you made a huge progress because in this
way you only have to avoid the snakes
and the spiders in order to have a
minimal control over your anxiety so
very often this state leads to
individual symptoms but sometimes when
many people in the population or in this
state it leads to a mass formation a
mass formation which is exactly the same
as an individual symptom but at the
collective level because what's what
happens in the masturbation is the
following
when many people are in this state
with a lot of free-floating anxiety for
instance
if at that moment a narrative is
distributed through the mass media
indicating an object of anxiety
and at the same time providing a
strategy to deal with this object of
anxiety
then all this free-floating anxiety
might connect to the object of anxiety
and there might be huge willingness in
the population to participate in a
strategy to deal with the object of
anxiety even if it is utterly absurd
because most people even realize that
their individual symptoms and their
collective behavior is absurd but it
won't take away that they will continue
to
go along with the narrative as if it is
true and that's what happens in a mass
formation all this free-floating anxiety
connects
to this object of anxiety there is this
willingness to participate in a strategy
to deal with the object of anxiety
no matter how
absurd it is and in this way people
experience like a first important
psychological process or advantage
um
they will have the feeling that they now
can control their anxiety a little bit
and they also anticipate a moment when
they can direct all this frustration and
aggression
at the object of anxiety or at the
people
that do not want to go along with the
strategy to deal with the object of
anxiety so that's the first step in
every major mass formation in history
every large scale mass formation as the
first step is the the object of anxiety
can be
the jews or the witches or the muslims
or no matter what the dirty unvaccinated
vaccination yes yes yeah um yeah that
one that one it just feels very personal
to me because i see it in people's eyes
um
so anyway it's a very very scary
phenomenon to
to witness
all right we've got uh disconnectedness
and loneliness meaning failure
free-floating anxiety all of these are
preconditions and then the fourth
yes yes well the the the fourth
condition is actually the free-floating
frustration i usually split them into
the free-floating anxieties the third
condition and the free-floating
frustration and aggression is the work
condition yes and then because you
should distinguish them from each other
actually because
some people for some people the anxiety
is the most important factor for other
people the frustration and aggression is
the most important factor but no matter
what it leads to this first important
step in the process of mass formation
meaning the coupling or the associated
the connection between
a certain mental representation of an
object of anxiety that is presented
through the mass media and then
uh the participation and the strategy to
deal with the object of anxiety for
instance the lockdowns to deal with the
virus that's the first step in the
process of mass formation but there is a
second step which is even more important
and it is that
because many people participate at this
at the same time in the strategy to deal
with the object of anxiety
people have the feeling of fighting a
collective heroic battle with the object
of anxiety and
that makes them feel connected again it
seems to create this new social bond
meaning that in this way
it seems as if the mass formation
eliminates the root cause of the
problems namely this lack of connection
there's disconnectedness between
the human being and its environment but
that's the point
you could say well what's the problem
what's the problem people feel
disconnected and now they feel connected
again they have they are they feel they
feel
reunited but the problem is that the
process of mass formation is very
leads to a very specific social bond
the mass a mass or a crowd is a group
that is not formed because individuals
connect to each other
the mass is a group that is formed
because each individual separately
connects to a collective ideal or to the
collective meaning that
this solidarity in the masses which is
so typical for the masses as soon as a
mass forms
the masses will typically talk about
solidarity and citizenship but this
solidarity
is never a solidarity between
individuals it's a solidarity of every
individual separately
towards the collective and even more
the longer the mass formation exists
the more
the social bonds between the individuals
will be destroyed and replaced by a very
strong social bond a very strong
solidarity of every individual
separately with a collective and that is
what explains
why for instance in iran a mother in the
end reports her son
someone with whom she used to have a
very strong individual bond
to the state for the sake of the
collective and that that also explains
why for instance in the corona crisis
everybody was full of solidarity and
talking about solidarity and at the same
time
strangely enough people accepted that if
someone got an accident on the street
we were not no longer allowed to help
that person or if we were all talk of
everybody was talking about solidarity
with the elderly and at the same time
they accepted strangely enough that if
their father and mother were dying at
home they were no longer allowed to
visit them so that's the strange
destructive mechanism of mass formation
that
it sucks all the energy away from the
bonds between the people and injects all
the energy in the bonds between the
individual and the collective leading
and the end always to a radically
paranoid atmosphere in which everyone
snitches each other and and in which
there are in the end
no relationships anymore between
individuals and individuals are all
completely isolated from each other
okay so
this leads
and i will confess up front there's so
much to be said about how the you know
if you take the picture that you've just
painted and you stand
and you look through the evolutionary
lens at it i think it
a lot of things resolve and then it
raises different questions i don't know
how to present that picture in a short
period of time it's it's going to take a
bunch of hashing out but
one thing that is true is that some of
what you have described
is the pathological version of a process
that clearly
has a
highly functional and desirable version
and
some will find this off-putting but
a religious community is obviously
highly effective at uh
getting through
what i would call bottlenecks
at resisting
confrontation with other
groups at
you know uh
resisting the the fashions and whims of
a society
those
religious communities
have the structure you're describing
right where you know
person a and person b
have a bond that comes from the fact
that they both feel they have a personal
relationship with someone who died 2 000
years ago
and whose origin story conflicts with
uh
what we understand of biology
right that's an interesting fact but it
is an also undeniable fact that two
people who do share a belief in that
story can find a kinship
very quickly just simply upon knowledge
that they have subscribed to the same
book all right um so
i i have argued many times that
religions long-standing ones are
evolutionarily adaptive
that they are adaptive in spite of being
literally false that their purpose is
what i call metaphorical truth
metaphorical truths are truths that are
functional that is to say even though
they're not literally right if you
behave as if they are right it
uh benefits you evolutionarily and so
the question then is
what do we make of mass formation
if mass formation is a
variation on a theme that is adaptive is
mass formation adaptive in which way and
so this leads us to the paradoxes that
you
point out why
why are intelligent people equally if
not more vulnerable to participating
in mass formation right that's a
a good question you haven't said it yet
but i know
from reading and listening to your work
that
you believe that these totalitarian
regimes that arise out of mass formation
always fail
i also believe they always fail
the question is does that mean that this
pattern is like
a tumor which kills its host and it has
no evolutionary meaning or
is this something more than a tumor and
the fact that the totalitarian system
fails does not mean that this is an
evolutionary paradox but you have to
stand somewhere else to see it i don't
know how clear those questions are but
um what do you hear so far
they are clear but they are very very
difficult
maybe and maybe not
yes because the masses there are there
are different types of masses
um
and indeed i do believe
that uh
the modern masses uh are always
self-destructive and and and
together with me i think that almost
every
uh scholar who studied the modern masses
throughout the last 200 years concluded
in the same vein they all concluded in
one way or another the masses are only
capable of destruction
and as soon as they destroyed everything
around them everything that that doesn't
belong to
to them they start to destroy themselves
uh we've you could you could never see
this more clearly than in the soviet
union in the soviet union uh which was
the the most totalitarian system that
has ever existed much more totalitarian
or it was much further in the process of
totalitarian and masculination than nazi
germany for instance and in the soviet
union you could see that first
the masses led by stalin started to
eliminate everyone who didn't belong to
them or who could not belong to them for
instance the aristocracy the small
farmers the large farmers then the
goldsmiths the jews and so on they were
all considered incapable of
of uh giving up their private property
and hence they could never become good
communists and
they had to be destroyed but after that
after everyone was eliminated
that was that couldn't join the masses
according to the masses themselves they
just started to eliminate the one group
after the other without
any logic in it nobody understood
anymore why suddenly this group had to
be destroyed destroy their heart or had
to be deported to the gulaks nobody
understood it anymore so that's the
blind irrational
destructiveness
that
is typical for the masses and that in
the end leads to the fact that to use
the words of hana aren't the masses in
the end typically become a monster that
devours its own children so
the problem
is
the monster devours its own children i
totally agree with this and i'm a big
fan of hannah around
the problem is that the people
who constituted the mass continue
and so evolutionarily speaking the fact
that the mass does not persist does not
mean that the mass was counterproductive
to the evolutionary i'm going to use the
term loosely objective
and this is what i uh
what i hope we can wrestle out of this
is that there are
um
there are two processes in human beings
that are hereditary
one of them is genetic and the other is
cultural
there are more but those are the two
biggies a dual inheritance system
and the problem is
the genes are the driver from the point
of view of the objective of
being a creature including a human
but in humans the much more interesting
part is the software level
right
and that software level can believe
different things at different times but
in some sense if you were to go back
through
the history of belief
of your own lineage
and you were to trace it back
uh you know obviously this becomes
impossible before the invention of
writing but let's say you could go back
a million years into your own lineage
and look at all of the things that your
ancestors believed
none of them were a failure
they were mostly wrong literally but
they did get you here and so
that's the question is mass formation to
me
um looks
like an adaptive pattern and it is
confusing to us because the content of
it is so upside down that we think this
just has to be madness which is in fact
why people
put the term psychosis on right this
appears to be a madness but the problem
is a true psychosis
is a dysfunction
right it is a failure to understand the
world
and
while the individual wrapped up in the
mass
fails to understand the world to be
certain they may well be in the better
position to get to the next chapter than
the person who says hey wait a minute
what are you talking about right and
that is
i think the most disturbing thing about
this is that the evolutionary story
does not offer us comfort just because
the mass fails right the mass doesn't
really fail that's not what happens um
and
um
just a couple more things in fact
there's no reason that you would
necessarily know but do you know why i
ended up in the public eye or how that
happened
do you know the evergreen story
yes i think i know it what happened
but please well i'm not gonna i won't
say terribly much except that my wife
and i were
extremely popular professors at a small
very liberal college and we had a very
uh
devoted and wonderful community of
students
that we taught evolution
and as
the woke revolution took over the
college
i initially ended up in a confrontation
with my faculty colleagues
and that confrontation with my faculty
colleagues resulted in
a group of students that i had literally
never met
arriving at my classroom and demanding
that i be fired for racism now i'm no
racist i'm quite the opposite
but it didn't matter to them it was
quite clearly a little a little mass but
here's the reason i raise it
two days before that happened i put a
model on the board
and the model this was something that i
was generating in my own head as i was
watching myself turned into
the witch in preparation for a witch
hunt by my colleagues and so i was
hashing this out with my students and
trying to explain to them what i thought
was unfolding and i wrote this model on
the board
that every witch hunt has four groups in
it right one group is the tiny number of
people who will initiate a witch hunt
then there's a
small but substantial group who will go
along with a witch hunt right then
there's a large number of people who
will say nothing
and then there is a small number of
people who resist and those are the
witches now as i was going through your
book with my wife heather hein last
night i found you have that model you
have it divided in three but it's the
same model and it has the same punch
line right the punch line is
your source of witches is the resistors
to the mass formation now when i wrote
that on the board i didn't know anybody
else had a model like that i didn't know
what mass formation was but the point is
in facing one it became apparent that
this was its inherent structure right
now i faced a little tiny mass right
inside my college a few hundred people
were highly animated by a nonsense story
that our college was being taken over by
white supremacy right which couldn't
have been farther from the truth
so anyway i got to see a little
miniature version of i mean i was
literally
um hunted on this campus they were
looking for me i was i was there the
witch in their eyes which was a
completely bizarre experience i heard
the story before i heard a story before
yes yes yes it must have been a terrible
experience and indeed it's like an
experience
of a mass formation a small scale mass
formation well a terrible experience on
the other hand how lucky was i
to get to experience it at that scale
before covet
right having
seen that up close
i knew it was like a training camp for
how you
look at such a bizarre phenomenon and
grapple with its meaning
anyway i don't need we don't need to get
lost in that story my point was the the
model that came out
yeah
okay can i respond to your question
please please
so uh in my opinion
i do believe
that mass formation in many respects
should be
considered a state
of madness and i know that i just said
that i don't use the term psychosis
but if you mean with madness a process
in which an individual
participates in something that will lead
that might
lead to his own destruction
then
you know maybe then i then i would say
that it is a kind of madness and and i
think it is even important to consider
it like that
because
i think that
whether you go along with the masses or
whether you defy the masses
in both scenarios you might
very well
become the victim of the masses
and
you know
starting stalin for instance started to
eliminate he eliminated in the end 60
percent of the of the members of his
young communist party without them
having
the possibility to prevent them from
being eliminated because it was almost
at random that they picked them and that
he he condemned them to death and in the
same way i i don't i think that that is
exactly what what is so important to
realize that you never
have to
try to destroy the masses
and the end they will always just
exhaust themselves potentially destroy
themselves but
what you should focus on
is preventing that they destroy you
and
that's if you if you if you look at the
psychological from the from a
psychological perspective if you look at
the mechanism then you soon
then you can see that the most crucial
thing i always repeat that that's the
most important message i can bring at
this moment is that
the better you understand the
psychological mechanism of mass
formation the more you understand that
it is just crucial
that the dissonant voices continue to
speak out and why
because they continue to continue to
speak out you exactly prevent that the
madness of the masses
and their leaders
becomes complete and that the masses
end up in the state in which they become
so fanatically convinced that everyone
who goes against them is actually
inhumane lacks solidarity lacks
citizenship is irrational and so on and
consequently should be destroyed uh uh
as a
exactly because he is so inhumane so
that this i think the entire process for
me shows that we are dealing with a
process which
leads people to a complete blindness a
complete self-destructiveness and a
complete absurdity in which you should
always consider as a kind of a state in
which people
in which the mental capacities of people
are very limited
um
i think
that many people try to explain mass
formation from the perspective of
that
just follow the money and you will
understand why they do it or just
uh just realize that they are that there
are power hungry individuals who who
want to be in charge of everything i
agree with hannah arendt that that is
not right
the typical the typical characteristics
of totalitarian leaders is not that they
are after the money or not that they
want more and more power the typical
characteristic of a totalitarian leader
is his radical ideological blindness the
radical ideological blindness which
pushes him to
impose his ideology
to the collective and to society no
matter what the coast is even
if it means that he will
be killed himself that he will lose
everything the typical totalitarian
leader will typically continue
uh
trying to impose his ideology to society
and then at the lower levels at the
lower levels of a totalitarian state you
find psychopaths perverts
people who are after the money hung uh
people who want power and so on but the
top level is characterized by
ideological blindness i think okay
uh here is the crux of our disagreement
and uh let me just say uh i hope the
better argument wins
right if it's your argument that will in
one way be comforting to me and i'm
happy to go there but
i am going
to try to persuade you that
what is madness at the individual level
is not madness at the collective level
and that evolutionarily speaking that
collective level matters more which is
why we see the pattern
and
um there are
first i want to go back to something you
said and i want to pressure test it a
little bit
so you said
that the indicator tell me if i've got
your meaning wrong here i'm paraphrasing
you but you said that the indicator that
this was madness was that people were
willing to engage
in behaviors that put them in danger of
destruction
is that is that effectively right
yes okay
but if we take that same logic
if i say well
you know
is a is a
player of american football
are they engaged in madness
because they are taking substantial
risks of harms to their cognitive
capacity to their
you know ability to to move around in
the world they might even
sustain a very serious injury crippling
one
um
that's a good question yes yes yeah so i
mean i would i'll just fast forward
obviously they're not crazy we can
explain their behavior from the point of
view of the rewards that they get
outweigh the risks that they take or at
least in their mind it seems likely that
they do
all right is that fair
yes okay
um what about a soldier
who goes into battle right knows that
they may not come back
right the person engaged in a very
dangerous
behavior
yet
you know obviously in wartime um you can
be
shot for deserting
uh in peace time or something like
peacetime the rewards that are offered
to your family
make it sensible
we can say the same we could say
something similar in the even more
radical case of a kamikaze pilot
or
a suicide bomber that there is an
analysis
whereby i mean if we just take the
trivial version
if
is it worth taking a substantial risk or
maybe even volunteering for a suicidal
mission if it puts your family at
sufficient advantage let's say that your
family was very jeopardized and you
engage in some behavior and you're gone
but the position of your children is so
much better than it would have been
that
the rationality is apparent it's brutal
right we may not like that it's there
but it
it's comprehensible
right
so are you with me so far no yes i am
definitely yes okay
so i have one other piece of my history
that i want to introduce here
when i was an undergraduate
i was working with
one of the great 20th century
evolutionary biologist guy named bob
trivers
and i wrote a paper
the final paper
that i wrote in his class
was on the holocaust
and the purpose of my paper
was
to
look into the claim
that hitler was a madman this was
something i heard very often as a young
person growing up far closer to world
war ii than i realized at the time i
mean i obviously knew how many years it
was but it seemed a long time ago and
now
obviously we're more than twice as far
out
[Music]
the
upshot of that paper
was that
hitler was a monster as everyone knows
and i believe that as strongly as anyone
maybe more strongly
but
what he did was not evolutionarily
irrational
from the point of view of his gene pool
it may very well have been rational and
this when i raise this point it always
puts me in an awkward position
um with people because they hear some
kind of defense of of it in there and i
mean the opposite what i mean is if
you're going to prevent this you have to
understand why it happens and so in any
case my point here is
i've been interested in the question of
why this takes place for a very long
time
until i ran into your work i didn't know
that there was this body of thought that
apparently goes back to before the
beginning of the 20th century on mass
formation
and so i've been looking at it from an
evolutionary perspective almost
uh strictly
but
these two things collide
right there you know it's a question of
consilience i think resilience meaning
when you s you happen on to the same
story from different disciplines and you
know there's a way to reconcile them and
suddenly you have a much more complete
picture because you know what what
you're describing is
um a process of individual psychology in
which an individual appears to be
utterly mad because they're saying
things that cannot be squared with
reality and they appear to be completely
committed to them even though they are
putting themselves in great danger
by subscribing right
and then
you know
in psychology you can see well okay but
there's a
psychology is an individual phenomenon
but there is a group manifestation there
is something about group psychology that
is also very real even though we can't
put it in an fr fmri machine and scan it
right but it's there it clearly is a
fact and then what i'm saying is from an
evolutionary perspective
we have the same dichotomy we have the
individual and their fitness and what we
fail to do well
is understand
the lineage
and its fitness
and i believe that the solution to the
puzzle that you're pointing to the
madness of these immense numbers of
people
is actually
a
diabolical rationality
and
that you know i'm sure you and i are
completely aligned in being terrified by
this process and the question is
is it worth discovering the nature of
lineage psychology
discovering that uh
hannah arendt's
correct belief that these ideologies
destroy themselves isn't really
comforting if this is the mechanism a
lineage uses to get through a historical
bottleneck
is that making sense
i think so
yes
but i i'm interested in learning more
about this diabolic rationality of the
masses can you can you
yes
is it irrational because i still don't
understand in what way you consider it
rational well
if you have the supraorganism this
larger organism than the masses
um
rational so i must tell you
uh you will be well aware of the
naturalistic fallacy
right if i describe that something is a
product of evolution i'm not defending
it and in fact although
humanity's best characteristics are all
products of evolution so are all of our
worst characteristics and i think it is
our obligation to uh augment and amplify
the honorable characteristics and to
banish
the
the evil ones but i don't want to
pretend that they're
not
comprehensible they're quite
comprehensive
and so
you know the point is look let's say
that uh
hitler had succeeded
right let's say that he had exterminated
the jews and then maybe he branched out
and uh you know he had left uh
the continent of europe
aryan maybe left the world area right
from the point of view of the genes in
his genome
that would have been a massive win
5 000 years after it had happened he
might have been largely you know
forgotten right the average person might
have the same relationship with hitler
that you know that i have with caligula
all right i can barely explain who that
is
and so the point is
the genes
are not
overly concerned
about
what the people who have those genes are
saying or thinking at any moment the
question is how do i get into the future
and one way to get into the future
is to eliminate people who share fewer
of those genes and to promote people who
have more of them and so
um you know if
hitler had
gone after people who parted their hair
on the left versus the right that would
be a paradox but because what he did is
he went after people who would if they
were eliminated be replaced by people
who were more closely related to him
this is a genetically
uh comprehensible strategy
right
it is
in fact
highly
effective and so
i don't want us to get lost in the fact
that um hitler was
dead wrong about the genetic superiority
of the people
that he was advancing
um
but
genes don't care about genes
genes want their particular spellings to
get into the future even if the gene you
know if we're talking about two genes
for a respiratory enzyme and one of
those genes is 50 percent more efficient
the one that's less efficient still
wants to get into the future and destroy
its competitor and i use want very
loosely obviously they don't really want
anything but they behave as if they want
these things and both versions of the
gene want to get into the future they're
not really interested in finding out
which gene is more effective they don't
care
okay can i respond to that please
yes you know
in my
two center opinion
you
now think
that
you you imagine in hitler who
acts and thinks in a rational way
and
who indeed
starts a program of protecting genes and
so on and so on and who succeeds in in
and implementing this rational program
but the pro the problem is i think
that
a dispersed mass formation seems
rational sometimes but it isn't in this
respect that for instance hitler started
eliminating uh the gypsies the jews the
the then he wanted to eliminate the
polish people the lithuanians
all the people with uh with limitations
in in germany and also all the people
with heart problems lung problems were
on his list all the germans with hard
problem problems and i think that
history has shown us that if this if
this process continues it starts to
become completely irrational wait also
from the perspective of the ideology of
the one who is
leading the masses and exactly because
the real function of this process of
mass formation
is not
ultimately
is not so much imposing a rational
ideology to the world the real function
of this process is
to handle and to control anxiety
frustration and aggression and this
process continues there is something in
the process of mass formation which
makes that it can never stop
because
first the masses as the masses each
they they
they
they have one object of anxiety that is
indicated in a narrative and they try to
eliminate to destroy this object of
anxiety but as they have as soon as they
succeed in destroying this object of
anxiety
what they will find out is that they
need a new object of anxiety simply
because the masses themselves don't want
to wake up because they would be
confronted again with all this
disconnectedness and all this
frustration aggression anxiety
does
want them aspiration to continue the
leaders know that the mass formation
must continue otherwise they will be
killed by the masses themselves if the
masses wake up they will typically
destroy their leaders so both the masses
and the leaders know that the phenomenon
of mass formation should not stop
meaning that after they have destroyed
the first object of anxiety they have to
do they have to find the second object
of anxiety which can be destroyed and
then a third a fourth a fifth and so on
so and now we see that in the end this
process of mass formation
in my opinion
uh
is not so much
while it seems
as if the masses and the readers and the
totalitarian state try to impose a
rational ideology for instance the
selection of the optimal genes to the
population
what really drives them is the handling
the the is their own anxiety and their
own their own
problems at the level of
disconnectedness meaning that
and
their attempt
to deal with their anxiety and their
attempt
to
create a new connection
is always a symptomatic one and then the
end always fails just because the masses
do not create new connection between
individuals the as i just explained as i
explained ten minutes ago or something
they they create the connection between
the individual and the collective
meaning that
in the end i think that mass formation
is always a kind of a symptom it's a
symptom
that
in which
which develops in an organism for
instance in a society and which
in the initial stage seems to solve a
problem but which in the end
becomes fatal and destructive for the
organism that develops a symptom so i
think you can perfectly compare it to a
tumor and
and in this respect i think that
gene the the the selection of genes
could be fruitful and selective if it
happened outside a phenomenon of mass
formation in a truly
enlightened mind
there it could be something rational
that leads to good results but the
problem is that as soon as it becomes
the the ideology of a mass it will i
think always be counterproductive and in
the end lead to the destruction of
uh also the masses themselves so that's
my first initial reaction to
your
yeah i now i now uh
i know why we're um
tripping over this stage of
of interaction
it has to do remember at the beginning
of the conversation i said that
when people who don't really know each
other very well meet they have only the
blunt
version of language
the problem is the word rational
right i don't mean
what i think almost everyone will take
from that term here and i just realized
what the distinction is right
let's say that hypothetically um
we have some friend
and they've fallen madly in love in fact
the term madly in love right
this person becomes
hard to interact with they are very
difficult you you know the person the
object of their uh of their love is
something that they can't be objective
about in the slightest right
it would be fair to say that this is a
state
of madness
right it is inconsistent with reality
right the chances that they've actually
fallen in love with somebody who's that
perfect are zero and yet even though
they rationally know that they still
feel it right
um is it irrational to fall in love
to be honest yeah i think it is
um oh then you're not doing it right
by which i don't mean
i think
i i agree with freud who said if you
don't lose your rationality from time to
time it means you have uh not so much to
lose i believe we should be rational all
from time to time okay okay no this is
perfect we're now
we're now finding out what how you use
this term right
your use of this term
uh runs into what i would say as a
failure mode at the point we encounter
somebody who's madly in love right
because i would say look
there is a reason that you are wired to
lose your
cognitive rationality yeah
and it has everything to do with your
long-term well-being right and your
long-term well-being isn't even your
long-term well-being it is directly
involved in your lineage as well being
going forward right so
that that irrationalities serves an
evolutionary purpose very clearly yes i
see but you need irrationality to
transcend yourself from time to time
uh yeah
yes but i do too i mean i use that you
know
and in fact i know that you and i are
going to agree here because uh one of
the things that caught my attention and
heather's attention in your work
is your
deep understanding of the problem of uh
reductionism
the hazard of reductionism to clear
thought right and so
what does it mean not to fall into that
trap what it means is that you have
little mechanisms
for allowing yourself not to be able to
answer what connects a and b
and say well i'm sure there's something
there and it could look like x maybe
i'll come up with something that i don't
really think does connect them but is in
principle a proof that something could
right and then with that spackle
covering that hole i can go and build a
model and it doesn't mean i think it is
or it isn't true but the point is the a
scientist who thinks
in a
an emergent way and works on things
complex enough that they don't
understand every element has to allow
themselves
leeway in places right you have to not
hold yourself to a perfectly high
standard for every step in the thing
that you're trying to understand or
you'll be
paralyzed so anyway that that is a kind
of irrationality that is essential to
high quality work
is that fair
yes at least yes
yeah
so uh
i don't know if you're eager to respond
in which case i don't want to stop you
but no no go ahead go ahead i'm
listening so i just want to i want to
now connect the the picture that we've
got right we now understand that we're
using rationality in specialized ways
right i'm arguing that sometimes
selection has us do something that if we
zoom in too close is perfectly
irrational right we have people saying
perfectly irrational things in a mass
formation
is the behavior of the mass
rational from the point of view of a
lineage getting into the future that's
the question and i'm perfectly happy to
swap out the term rational for some
other term
but successful adaptive
right and therefore that the belief
system the the
uh irrational belief system
doesn't need to persist in order for the
strategy to be a success yes yes yes
okay yes you maybe
it could be considered rational from
this point of view maybe
uh but i believe
um nietzsche for instance nietzsche
friedrich nietzsche the german
philosopher would probably say that mass
formation is rational from in this in
this in this respect that that helps the
weaker people
to survive because they connect to each
other in a mass and they they they start
to belong to a supra organism
or i i remember certain
uh quotes of nietzsche who go in that
direction but anyway it could be
considered rational i think from this
point of view but i also think there
could be
a different type of rationality in the
process of mass formation i think and
allow me to to to tell me please
or to describe
another perspective that could
make us see that the process of mass
formation maybe has some rationality in
it you know
when a mass formation forms when a mass
emerges in a society
there is always a group who doesn't go
along
with the masses
and
this group
is typically put
under a huge pressure
and under these circumstances
this group can
go in two directions
it can form a mass itself
and in this way we have a small mass and
a large mass we polarize and very often
in that case the small mass is destroyed
just because there are two groups
functioning to the same according to the
same destructive principles and very
often the small group is destroyed not
always but very often but then this
group has also
another option
if this group
decides to do something
very specific he will not only survive
but he will go through an extremely fast
process of mental
evolution and
it is the following
that this group if this group decides to
continue to speak out
and
to stick to the principles of humanity
itself
while the mass is typically dehumanized
then this group
at a very fast pace in a very short
period of time
will become more and more aware of these
principles of humanity and will become
stronger and stronger
uh both at the mental and at the
physical level that is perfectly that
was perfectly described by sulcinegen
among many other people who who
described how in the gulags most
prisoners became radically beast-like
they started to behave in a beastly
manner
and they started to crush each other's
skulls just to steal each other's foot
and and each other's clothes and and
they became even worse for each other
than than the guards were already for
them and so on but solstenitchin said
for one reason or another there was also
a small group of group of prisoners who
did who went in exactly the opposite
direction in this pool of darkness they
chose to represent a little bit of light
and they they remained loyal to the
principles of humanity to certain to
certain ethical standards and so since
observed something very specific in this
small group some of them died
but many of them became stronger and
stronger and stronger at the mental
level and at the physical level and so
since said like that for him he won the
nobel prize for this wonderful book at
the gurak archipelago where he described
this among other things and he described
how
he knew
prisoners who entered the gulags
sickly and because they were so loyal to
their ethical principles they became
stronger and stronger at the physical
level and in the end they survived the
gulags and
so that if you if you
look at mass formation and the total
italianism from a little bit of distance
then you see a very typical process
which could be rational in this respect
that it is nature
that puts a lot of pressure that that
makes that is a large group a large
organism puts a lot of pressure on a
small group and pushes it in a direction
and on a pathway where it would never go
without the pressure of the masses of
the large group and in which
in this way
nature creates like a mechanism that
gives birth to
a new and more clear awareness of what
it means to be human
uh and and
in which it produces like a kind of
awareness in human beings and the kind
of strength that would not exist without
this dehumanizing organism that the
masses is we could also look at it like
that then it also makes sense then it is
also rational but from a completely
different perspective
well first of all i cannot help but see
in what you've just described exactly
the experience that happened
during the pandemic because
i'm
i will guess that you've had the same
experience that i have had where the
pandemic has strained relationships that
felt extremely solid beforehand but it
has also forged a tremendous number
of very high quality connections with
people who have extraordinary capacities
and who amplify each other's
humanity that's been
the silver lining for i think many of us
is that we
we have
met so many
high quality courageous insightful
people yourself among them uh in my case
um
and so that's a very powerful force i
hear you saying
that maybe the uh the troubling
authoritarian mass that it could be
rational in the sense that it creates
this reaction that's very high quality
i think they are both rational and you
know
one of the things that's hard to see
evolutionarily is we tend to think well
what is the best strategy and the point
is well you've got strategies and
counter strategies and
you know i have written on my my notes
here mass versus anti-mass because there
is something about the process of the
people
who
do appear to have resisted the madness
and to have
shown such strength of character that
has some of the same characteristics
right um
we have scratched our itch in a very
different way
but nonetheless
the camaraderie
in your description
it is the terror of loneliness and
the inability to interpret the world
that drives people to scratch that itch
by signing on to a nonsense story that
gives the promise of some kind of
salvation
and
that thing created a world in which some
of us became obsessed with making sense
from actual evidence
difficult as that is and it created a
camaraderie of a different kind so
basically the point is
everybody's looking for camaraderie and
there are a couple different paths one
of them is easy
and very dangerous the other is uh
well dangerous to the individual at an
extraordinary level
um but nonetheless does bring you in the
same kind of contact and it is very uh
reassuring to discover that there are
others for example
oh go ahead
no i still i think that there is
or we should watch out that we do not
become
a real mass just because
um there is a i think the
the most important distinction between
uh
sound and fruitful group formation and
the mass formation is that in a group in
a in a in a
in a good group formation
uh
there is on the one hand
a certain bond between in between the
individual and the collective but also
the bonds between individuals are strong
and there is a real solidarity between
the individuals as well and i think
that
i also i i discovered many new
friendships during during the crisis and
i in my
experience
it existed of really strong bonds
between the individuals i don't think
that i started to form a mass with other
people uh like look when
you and me are talking now we can have a
different opinion yes i was just going
to say this yeah that's how we know this
isn't a mass
yes
we haven't agreed on some abstraction
even you know if we were going to right
the group of people that we are now
mutually in contact with
have resonated with mass formation as an
idea and we have seen it
move around so if there was an idea that
we were all going to sign on to and not
notice you know
that there was an incompleteness here or
a paradox there that would be it but
you're right we're not doing that and
that is
uh maybe that's the uh
the check
that we need to know that we are not in
a mass is are we holding each other's
feet to the fire or not right and i
don't want to be part of any
uh group that isn't willing to honorably
hold each other's feet to the fire for
one thing that's how we make sense
that's the whole point of the endeavor
right
we will you know we will freeze
ourselves in place with a narrative that
isn't true if we don't uh
pressure test it and uh challenge each
other
indeed
yes but i think suddenly it seems to me
to be a very attractive idea or a very
attractive question like
indeed on the one hand we could say
that
from a rational point of view the
smartest choice
is to go along with the masses
and to feel protected by the masses
on the other hand we could also say no
it's the other way around it's better to
belong to the small group because if you
do the right thing as a small group if
you stick to your ethical
you
principles
go through this fast process of
evolution which has been described by
many people and which maybe is the is
the real destiny of the human being
to become an ethically aware human being
uh
with an enlightened mind um
and
yeah
perfect um and you know i keep trying to
explain to people who
you know
as i'm sure happens with you people will
come up and they will say you're very
brave i admire you this that and the
other i try to explain
this situation left no choice i
literally do not know how i would have
done the other thing right i wouldn't
have been able to stand it for five
minutes
and and so
it is
that which you know
does you know it does rob it of a
certain amount of courage i didn't have
a choice i didn't make the choice to do
this it just simply was the only thing
um that that was tolerable
but it does raise this other question
one of the things i saw so i saw
two mass formations in a row right
there's the mass formation
uh around woke ideology
which
did the same thing it created a
group of people who
[Music]
came together from very different
perspectives uh battled the
irrationality of the claims
and it was it was a a wonderful
chapter
then when kovid came
it shocked me because it took the group
of people
who had
formed this
anti-mass
to the woke ideology and it divided it
some of the people who
saw right through the woke ideology fell
right in line
with the uh
i mean i call it uh i call them
medically woke
right it's equally irrational and yet
and they've demonstrated the capacity to
see through irrational things and the
courage to do it and yet in this case
something about this story was in their
blind spot
i can't i can't understand it um maybe
maybe you do why is it that people who
have resistance to this in one context
don't have resistance in another yes i
think that the the the emergence of the
culture in our society was like a
preparatory face for the large mass
formations that still have to come
because
um
in my opinion the corona crisis was the
first real mass formation because
exactly because it has this
baffling characteristic that it split
all the existing groups into that's
that's the signature of a real mass
formation it is energetically so strong
that it re-divides
reorganizes the entire social structure
um but yes and and and once once a one
real mass formation emerged in society
very often a second one and a third one
and a fourth one follows just because
the mass formation
recreates
recreates the conditions that made it
emerge
mass formation started
on the basis of loneliness and
disconnectedness but the mass formation
itself leads to even much more
disconnectedness and loneliness while it
seems to do the opposite in the
beginning it destroys the social bond
further and after a mass formation there
is even more lonely people more
disconnected people which
very often makes that a a second mass
formation and a third one emerges so
shortly after the first one
uh uh ceased to or or disappeared a
little bit in the background
so um
[Music]
i believe that
uh the the phenomenon is very well known
if a real mass information emerges then
something happens something something
very specific specific happens in
certain people which is referred to as a
mental surrender people who were
convinced
anti-totalitarians or anti-fascists or
no matter what
very often suddenly become fascists
themselves as soon as the fascist mass
formation emerges just because they
don't like the they don't have the
mental energy or the psychological
strength
to to prevent that order all the energy
is sucked away from their mental
representations and invested in the
mentor and only this limited set of
mental representations that is shared by
the group so in many people i know
personally many people who wrote article
many people i knew i know a few people
who wrote
articles about the dangers of
technocratic totalitarianism about
the the danger of the dangers of extreme
collectivism and conformism and then the
corona crisis started and in the brink
of an eye they conformed to the
mainstream narrative and they declared
everyone crazy we didn't go along with
the mainstream narrative so
uh that's that's the strange thing
in my in
in my case exactly well not the opposite
happened but something different happens
i had exactly the same experience as the
one that you described and i i talked
about it in numerous podcasts before
this one that in the beginning of the
crisis
i realized immediately i will speak out
i have no other option and i will
continue speaking out no matter what it
it it brings
to me or no matter what the consequences
are i just immediately knew if i don't
speak out now
i will never have to speak out and i
will do it i will just do it and i
started to speak almost without
uh
i didn't have the feeling that i choose
for it i knew it i will speak out
right uh in my case i would say
i had had that discussion with myself
decades ago
right i think in part in my case growing
up as a jew
as close to the end of world war ii as i
did i was born in 1969 so a quarter
century later but nonetheless close
enough that it was on people's minds
many people i knew had seen it
[Music]
and my basic feeling was
i looked at all of the people
who waited too long to speak out who
did something that
leaves me frustrated even hearing what
their response was and my thought was
uh there i will not i will not go along
with such a thing right even even at the
cost of my life i would much rather
take my best shot
and not be left with the question of why
didn't i do more
than uh
to be stuck and
so anyway at the point that you get
to the thing
you know the choice is just made
yes
as well i think because my family also
has this well
tradition of speaking out no matter what
the ghost is certain people in my in my
ancestors did that
and
um
i also think that
i also like when i started to work at
[Music]
i
university i and i saw how how many flawed research
there was i immediately started to
review it and i started i i i tried to
show what the problems were with this
kind of research and after after two
years at university ninety percent of
the people was very angry with me and
the other ten percent really respected
me and
and i i had this
also there i i in in that period
throughout the last 20 years
i really became used to having 90 of the
people against me and trying to continue
to speak out in a very quiet way without
trying to hurt anyone and
being respectful as much as possible but
still i always refused to shut up and
when the corona crisis started i knew
like look
this time i will speak in public space
i used to speak out in only in the
academic world but i knew like this one
i will speak out in public space and i
don't know if that was also something
that you experienced but
while i continued to speak out people
were throwing mud at me here in the
belgian newspapers it happens all the
time even now
constantly uh
the
[Music]
thereof if the mainstream media
talk about me it's always in a very
negative and condescending way
and um but
as i
practiced and as a and as i as i try to
continue to speak out without really
becoming aggressive myself or without
just
calm and quiet i really had this feeling
that i felt as if as a very
warm and soft power grew stronger than
me and
you know
this experience in itself for me
compensates for everything that i have
lost in the crisis which is not so much
i have been excommunicated from certain
groups at university
i won't be too dramatic about it
and but but but still no matter what i
would lose
i would
want to
give it
if i have this phenomenon in return that
you feel the soft
power that is increasing in myself and
that that for me as the as the essence
of life actually
i agree and i i wish i knew how
to convey what you're describing to a
larger audience i will say it's very
interesting to hear
um that you have
polarized the institutions you've been
part of i've had that same phenomenon
i've polarized every institution i've
been a part of and you know when people
who don't who haven't had that
experience hear it they think how
terrible that you're polarizing and the
answer is
no i want the respect of the people that
i think
their respect means something right if
you polarize an institution and all of
the people
who are
uh
you know phonies or corrupt or cowards
if they all you know line up against you
and the people that you actually admire
are like
ready to acknowledge yeah
you make sense then the answer is well
what else would you have done do you
want the respect of people who aren't
respectable i don't right and so the yes
the um
what you are describing what i think i
have also experienced
is a training program for something it's
a developmental experience that
generates certain
characteristics that if you have them
you're not eager to trade them for
something else right
right i mean i feel the same way in some
sense
about uh
you know i have what people describe as
dyslexia
it interfered with my ability to do
normal school work
but i don't look at it as something that
i lost i looked at it as something that
forced me into patterns that i
wouldn't know what to do without and so
um anyway i yeah
the path of somebody who polarizes
institutions is not
necessarily fun
hour to hour but uh viewed on a long
time scale it does
it's very clarifying and um
i wish more people
realized that and didn't fear
uh
causing people to
reject them um
yes yes i agree i agree
there is something
there is this um
uh in the talmud says if i'm not
mistaken
if a human being
uh does not speak
does not articulate the words that
emerge
in him or herself and that seem to be
honest and sincere birth
then he will slowly start to lose
his soul and
i do believe the opposite is true as
well if you practice and if you can't
constantly try to articulate the words
that you consider to be sincere and
honest words no matter what the
consequences are and no matter how the
group reacts to it
then you will
slowly start to
be more aware of your own existence as a
human being you will start to feel
stronger you will feel your real
identity
you will
be less in need of all kinds of ego and
and and
fake identities and i think for me the
human being
is intrinsically
dependent on the quality of his speech i
think that the speech
the quality of our speech and then i
don't mean the aesthetical qualities but
the the sincerity and of speech and the
courage
of your words
um
determines in a straightforward way
the strength of your soul and the
strength of your mind i think and i
think the better we realize that the
more we know that
maybe we should tolerate that
they take everything away of us in the
end
uh but we should make sure that they
don't take away our humanity and and and
that we
if we if we have to die that we doubt
that we die with our principles and not
without
um
that's something that i well i became
more much more aware of during this
crisis like like what
is important and what is not important
uh in in a in this life here
yeah i think that's uh beautifully said
and uh
at the risk of tarnishing it i will
put it in what i take to be the
evolutionary context
you know people are often
prone to you know ask what's really
special about humans right and they come
up with all kinds of uh things but
really in the end it is speech and the
reason that it is speech is because that
allows two minds to share ideas abstract
ideas and this is the core of what we do
that other creatures cannot
right
so anyway in saying the quality of your
speech and
the uh
the integrity of it and uh i would argue
the capacity of it to convey uh
important nuance
um you're really talking about the thing
about us that
uh
unites the individual with something
else right speech
yes you can talk to yourself and you
know
i think a lot of us who care about
speech probably do but
um but the point is
to say that your speech is important is
to imply
that your relationship the integrity of
your relationship and your capacity to
interact with somebody in a deep high
bandwidth fashion is also at the core of
you know the most meaningful element of
being human and i 100 percent agree with
that
um yeah yeah
i think that our relationship
the social bond between humans is always
intrinsically linguistic in nature
because we can't we have no other option
than to constantly try to interpret the
other the expressions on the face uh
everything
is interpreted by us we have no other
option we constantly do and so it's it's
it's it's indeed
we are
linguistic entities for each other
and we can only connect and to each
other through language
or our the nature of our connection is
linguistic
intrinsically
yes i think the art of speech
um is the answer i think to all
totalitarianism
yes
now heather and i
many times have
uh discussed
the fact that modernity
has taken many essential human functions
and it has
shifted them to the market
right whereas a person 200 or 300 years
ago
would have had many close contacts they
probably would have known many of them
for
their whole life
they would have had a life partner
they would have produced children almost
automatically those relationships would
have been very important to them all of
those things would be true
now children are very optional partners
are increasingly
optional and as the pandemic set in
it dawned on us
that
people trapped without even a single
person that they could look in the eye
and say
is this making sense to you because i
hear everybody saying nonsense and i
don't know what to make of it if you
didn't have
one person that you could trust
to say yeah i see it too
you were in grave danger of not making
any sense at all
and i i wonder if that's part of what
happened is that lots of people who
didn't have partners because you don't
absolutely need one
um
got
isolated in a way that maybe is almost
without precedent
of course it is it is all like
stalin isolated his population because
he knew that they were much more
vulnerable for propaganda than he
intentionally did isolate his population
because he knew that they were
it was much easier to
to use propaganda in that case
hitler didn't but but the the the effect
was it was was the same actually as mass
formation exists it all it also
spontaneously creates isolation and and
uh and a certain loneliness but here in
this case with the corona crisis we have
never seen such an extreme state of
isolation of the population never i
think
and at the same time people were
constantly
uh bombarded with these messages with a
little bit with propaganda through their
iphones through their television through
radio constantly so it was the most
extreme
example
uh of of of an optimal situation to use
propaganda
so a couple things i want to make sure
we we highlight here
one is
your point
about
one mass formation often follows another
i was going to ask you about this
because what i've seen
and i almost wonder if there's not
an addiction
where
because people feel isolated and i will
argue in a moment that that is
the most
because our ancestors were starving and
because no human is equipped to
survive alone in the world
being isolated is a terrifying
experience because it's basically a
precursor to starving to death
[Music]
so when people feel that isolation
either because it's induced by somebody
who wants to control them or because
it's a natural consequence of
technologies and economic systems that
separate us
they have this
desire
to replace something that they've lost
they don't necessarily know what it is
but when it is offered
in the form of
sign up for this narrative and you
suddenly become part of this large
enthusiastic group right we're going to
be the winners we're going to end up
with the food and all you got to do is
believe these things and say them and
punish the right people and you can be
one of us right that satisfies
it relieves the pressure of the threat
right
and then the point is at some point
coronavirus stops being a compelling
narrative or the
slate of beliefs is so far off the
evidence and podcasts are so full of
people talking about you know the
hazards that you may have exposed
yourself to if you believe these things
that people don't they're not
enthusiastic about it anymore and so
then the point is well
they're still looking for something that
causes them to feel safe and
together with people and so they're
they're primed for some other topic
and i you know i almost i
i watched
um
trump
as this uniting force right we have to
do away with this demon
become
the
public health narrative right they're
obviously
almost unrelated topics
and yet people went seamlessly from one
to the other because it was they were on
the same team and they had become
addicted to that team
and
um
you know i i do wonder where we are now
uh obviously as you also you it was also
remarkable i think that as soon as the
corona narrative disappeared a little
bit in the background uh
we
seemed to fulfill a little bit the same
function there was again this tendency
to consider the good and the bad uh very
much in black and white and then also
there was like a new object of anxiety
and the new uh intolerance for dissonant
voices uh also this new enthusiasm this
new solidarity
um yes
i also think that at the moment now
it seems that
mass formation became a little bit
milder mitigated a little bit but i
don't think we are rid of
so we see that the consequences of of
the of the mass formation are very very
severe at a psychological level like i
don't know how it is in the united
states but i think it is the same but
now that students are allowed to come
back to university to follow courses on
campus they don't show up anymore only
five percent shows up
the same holds for the professors and
the assistants at university the
buildings are empty
in companies i hear the same story and
uh the the the cultural sector the
theaters and the movies nobody shows up
so that shows us something very specific
namely that the mass formation was
extremely destructive at the level of
the social bond
and
that you know a social bond
people always at the same time
find their deepest satisfaction in the
social bond but they also have to
overcome a certain resistance to take a
step to the other because of all kinds
of things shame anxiety uncertainty
self-awareness and so on and so if if if
the energetic
the psychological energy invested in the
social bond goes below is a certain
threshold then you typically see that
people prefer to stay home and that's
what they do now that's what they do now
many people stay home or many people
don't go back to work don't go back to
university
and this probably will prepare them for
an even more more intense example of
mass formation in the nearby future
unless
again and that's so important
the dissonant voices really do their
best continue to speak out and that's
that's i'm confident that
there is a group of people who is very
determined now that they won't
remain silent and that they will speak
out so i'm also i'm confident that in
here the years to come probably will be
will be very difficult years
but the group who uh
defies the masses and and refuses to buy
into the mainstream narrative will be
large and and determined enough i think
to keep open a certain path no matter
how difficult it is
so that the authoritarian system cannot
destroy everything um
well we have to figure out how to retain
our ability to speak
to the world i think the the people who
have emerged globally it's a very
powerful
group of people and i think we you know
we are we are well positioned to speak
um
to speak carefully about what's
unfolding and i agree that what is what
is to come may be well worse than what
we've already
seen
i will say to your point about
people not going back to
university
to their jobs etc we've seen some of
that in the u.s i think it's not quite
the same but i will say having had
the opportunity after two years of
really not
straying very far from home
i have
now traveled a couple of times
a little bit around the u.s
a little bit to britain
and
i am struck
by
i it's very hard for me to explain and i
want to be very cautious because it's
possible that it's in my mind and i'm
not actually seeing what's in the world
but i feel a kind of unease
in
the population that people have gone
back
to activities that they remember they're
taking pleasure in
being in the sun things like this but
there is this sense and i definitely
have it
that i have now watched
um a
spasm of what took place
uh in russia before the formation of the
soviet union what took place in germany
before the nazis
i have seen that begin to happen
and i am aware of what it implies
and
in some ways the most difficult question
for me
is
if this relaxes
how is it that
that we go back
to living with each other
i mean for one thing once you've seen it
happen and you know well this is the
confirmation of what many of us have
said which is it can happen here right
it can happen across the west
um
so the that means that it must be an
extremely high priority
that we figure out what makes it happen
that we figure out how to get in the way
and that we figure out how
to rescue people that we know from it as
it's happening so that it doesn't take
them over
right but i don't know how to do that
and i wonder if everybody is sort of
feeling this tension of now having
watched us divide into these teams that
yes could turn into something genocidal
it didn't in this case
yet at least um
what do we do with that knowledge
yeah that's a good question that's a
good question of course and i think that
well
as fast as possible we should try to
talk with each other again also people
who found themselves in a different camp
who
the people who so we have to have to
restart the dialogue and and and
the dialectical process between each
other
uh that's one thing but i think that at
the same time i'm convinced that the
problem of the emerging the mass
formation and totalitarianism
can never be really solved as long as we
stick to our reductionist mechanist
fueled men in the world because the the
root cause and the ultimate cause of of
the phenomenon of totalitarianism i
agree with hannah arendt in that respect
definitely that it is to be situated in
a and the mechanist materialist ideology
not mechanist science because science
has nothing to do with it actually but
it is a scientific ideology when science
turns into an ideology that means
science once was an answer to dogmatic
and and institutionalized religion but
slowly
it became an ideology itself it became a
set of dogmas and a set of
preached prejudices itself and
and and
very specific ideology an ideology which
believed that the entire universe could
be reduced to a materialist machine
and perfectly described in a rationalist
way perfectly manipulated and controlled
in a rational way and that rational
understanding should be the basis the
cornerstone of human living together i
disagree with that i really disagree i
disagree in this respect that the
rational knowledge
is very important and the process we
have been going through as a society
throughout the last few hundred years is
very important but only
if it leads to the next step i i don't
know if you're familiar with the work of
remy tom one of the famous
mathematicians of the 20th century and
one of the founders of systems theory
and he said
ultimately he said this part of reality
that can be understood in a rational way
is rather limited and the rest of
reality you can only know by
emphatically resonating with it and and
and that that for me it took me until i
was 35 years old
when i became familiar with the with the
mathematical basis of systems theory to
suddenly
start to understand and it was a true
revelation for me
that
um
our rational understanding was never
capable of grasping the true essence of
life
around us and that we needed a different
way of knowing the world and renee tom
uses the word resonating knowledge
to
[Music]
feel or to be connected with the essence
of the world around us also niels bohr
also had this wonderful statement he
said when it comes to atoms language can
only be used as poetry you can't you you
can only use language as poetry when you
want to grasp something of the strange
irrational behavior ultimately of of
[Music]
elementary particles and it also makes
me think of several
statements of several uh um principles
in the samurai culture in japan where
they said that in every art when you
master an art
or a craft or something there is first
the stage this rational stage in which
you learn certain rules in which you
learn certain techniques that you can
understand in a rational way and that
you have to learn in a rational way
but the real the the goal of the of of
the learning process is not the
techniques in itself the goal of the of
this rational stage of of the learning
process is always to be
come in touch with something to start to
develop a certain feeling a certain
feeling that you can never never
articulate perfectly in a rational way
but which is the real goal of the of the
learning process and the summer i said
it's one thing to learn a technique but
it's more difficult to forget it again
and if you don't succeed in forgetting
it before you go to the battlefield they
said you will die on the battlefield so
you need this
other type of knowledge
which is more resonating knowledge which
is also a kind of knowledge which
really
gives a certain touch a certain feeling
of connection with
uh with what is out there
and which makes you aware i think of the
eternal principles of of of of of the
real outside of you the eternal
principles of the mystery of all life
around you and i thought these
principles i think these principles
which are like the principles of
humanity the principles of nature the
prince the ethical principles um
it are these principles that should be
the real cornerstone of human living
together and not
rational knowledge that no matter how
important rational knowledge is is
always temporary it's always done it's
always it will always be renewed it will
always i mean
the real
the only thing that can organize a
fruitful living together i think as
principles and not rational knowledge
well um
that is the basis of several
conversations we might have i have a
whole different taxonomy that i have a
feeling results in the same conclusion
right my sense is
the universe can in principle be
understood mechanistically we are a
million miles from the ability to do it
on the topics that matter most
right we are in our infancy with respect
to understanding biology and psychology
and
society
so
at some level we are stuck in the
predicament that you are describing not
because
the world isn't mechanistic but because
the mechanisms are so complex that we
don't even have the tooling to
investigate them yet right i mean if we
look at mandelbrot's
um you know
investigation of fractals as a solution
to um
the by the math of biology basically
right we needed a different kind of math
to even begin to ask those questions and
i think we are in the same place our
science is much better with simple
phenomena than it is with complex
phenomena because that's where we learn
to do it
but i 100 resonate with the idea that
the whole goal of the exercise of
learning things in a conscious way is to
stop doing them consciously that's when
you really get good at something
and
so we have to think that way and the
other thing i would add
which i heard implied in what you said
is
that a mechanistic understanding even if
you had it even if you had the complete
mechanistic picture of the universe
it would not
deal with the values issue you could
reverse engineer why we hold the values
that we do but the fact is
we have to at some level
stop trying to justify the values on the
basis of the mechanism it doesn't work
right we have to say something like
[Music]
it is glorious to be alive on this
planet and if that is true we are
obligated to deliver that experience to
people in the future to not deny it to
them by destroying what we have right
that is an ethical obligation
um
and if you become too mechanistic you'll
say something like well
it's all gonna be destroyed anyway
there's nothing we can do about it right
the earth will be destroyed
the galaxy will be destroyed ultimately
the universe will be destroyed so it's
all for naught why are we obligated to
you know to defend what we've got and
the answer is you just failed the
ethical test you may have passed the
mechanistic one but you failed the
ethical one
you got the values wrong so
um
in any case yeah it's
uh and what you said at the beginning
particularly resonates right what you
said is that this um
i don't want to put words in your mouth
but it was words to the effect of
that science has become not only a
mechanism for studying things but it's
become an ideology is that what you said
yes yes i i agree with this and not a
sophisticated ideology either it's
become a very narrow-minded ideology
and the uh
the costumes of science have been taken
to be a good indicator of who knows what
they're talking about and
it's nonsense
as the corona pandemic
demonstrated just so
extremely
indeed indeed yes and that's a strange
thing when people blind believe blindly
believe in rationality they end up being
radically irrational that's the strange
that's that's one of the strange things
when you make science into an ideology
you often believe that you
um
uh
these people who make science into an
ideology often believe that they are
extremely rational but in the end they
become radically irrational that's
something very strange
but as you as you said
[Music]
well
the question as to what extent reality
is mechanistic in nature is a very
important one and i think that
in the end we might have a very fruitful
disagreement i believe but it depends it
depends of course whether you how you
define
a
mechanistic the the word mechanistic
because yeah what does that mean the
word mechanistic
i i
yeah do you mean that everything can be
reduced to the elementary laws of of of
mechanics the mechanical laws of newton
um how do we define that it's it's not
easy to define it or for instance the
mechanisms of language
i i
i'm well
as soon as you
if you study
uh
material reality
uh
at least that's what
the physicists of the 20th century
concluded then you soon
have to conclude that subjective
experience
and all kinds of psychological phenomena
have a certain impact on mechanistic on
on on the on on the behavior of
of the material elementary particles
and
that for me seems to be an indication
that we actually can never succeed in
reducing everything
to the laws of mechanics but they can be
wrong i can be wrong well
i would say we want to we want to parse
this very carefully
the
my argument would be as far as we know
everything
could be
reduced up till
the point we get to
heisenberg uncertainty
and then the question is is heisenberg
uncertainty an observational problem or
is it built into the structure of the
universe i believe it actually has to be
built in there has to be
uncertainty at the ground level
but short of that
i would argue that in principle the
universe appears to be
comprehensible mechanistically but in
practice it never will be right in other
words the um
the computational power it is not the
correct way to think about the universe
that you could in principle you know you
could in principle understand a baseball
game at the level of the molecules but
it's not a good way to understand a
baseball game no
no it's too cumbersome yeah and also the
organizing principle has to be situated
i think at the level of the intentions
of the of the players involved i believe
but and also like well you know
what's
definitely
certain is that the universe will always
be unpredictable that's something that
was very clearly shown by complex
dynamical systems theory that
even
that every complex dynamical system
even if you know the formulas the
mathematical formulas that determine the
system
then still it will be unpredictable
simply because of the character the
characteristic of
uh sensitivity for initial conditions in
complex dynamical system it will remain
forever unpredictable
um because
differences in the state of the system
that are infinitely small
can create a radically different
behavior in the system meaning that you
can never measure precise enough to
predict how the system will behave so
the universe is definitely unpredictable
so the idea of laplace that one time
there could be a computational force
that is strong enough to predict the
entire future is
rejected
but if that means
that
that the universe behaves in an
irrational way that's another question
and
i'm inclined to believe that it does
actually i'm inclined to believe that it
does behave in an irrational way well
yeah i think this is a potentially
productive disagreement uh maybe for
another time but
yeah there is a question about why those
systems are you know is all of that
unpredictability the result is it
cascading from uncertainty at a very
fine-grained level i believe that it is
i'm not wedded to that position but i
believe that it is and i believe we
don't have a fully deterministic
universe but we do have a mechanistic
universe and that's
that's the difference that i'm arguing a
deterministic universe to me would make
no sense i mean for one thing it would
invalidate the meaning that we take from
evolutionary dynamics completely
if all of those dynamics were set in
stone from the moment the universe began
that's a very different phenomenon than
an environment in which you have
creatures competing over limited
resources which implies that one could
win or another one could win and then
one does right
um but anyway this becomes a very uh
intractable philosophical conversation
very quickly
ndts yes
well well
um is there anything more you want to
say uh as we wrap up
uh no not really we have been talking
about a lot and and i liked it very much
uh i want to thank you very much for
inviting me uh and for bringing my book
to the attention of the people yeah do
you have a copy i do not have a copy or
i would hold it up do you have a copy
well i will send no i don't i i
no i gave my i gave my copy to to eric
clapton actually thank you
and now i will uh i will receive 10 new
copies
but but i don't have one here now
i will i will have you send one brett oh
great great excellent well i look
forward to it um i will say this was a
great conversation um and i feel
that i have encountered a a kindred
spirit and a fellow polarizer of
institutions and you know that's gotta
be that's gotta be good so this has been
extremely enjoyable i hope people who
have uh watched and or listened have
also found it interesting i know
everyone will have found it challenging
as i did
um but in any case i hope we uh we meet
in person soon yeah me too likewise i
hope i do oh one more thing where do
people find you
yeah that's a good question i only have
a facebook page and the linkedin page
but now i will start a sub stack um uh
in one or two weeks
at this moment it's maybe my own
facebook but it's it's uh yeah you can
find me on facebook or on linkedin
uh but i will go on substance in the
nearby future you're you're one of very
few people who are uh
in this milieu who are not on twitter
but not because anyone threw you off or
were you thrown off no no no no i never
i never tried to go on twitter and then
before the corona crisis i i almost
didn't know that there was that there
was such a thing like social media
but then
now i
yes well i think in your business of
studying mass formation you need to you
need to be aware of
social media uh all right and the name
of your book
uh the psychology of totalitarianism
psychology of totalitarianism which is
of course uh a derivation of hannah
arendt's earlier title which was uh
origins of totalitarianism it's a
mixture between the origins of
totalitarianism and the psychology of
the crowd of gustavo
wow very good
no got it all right well people should
people should pick it up and uh read it
and then hopefully we can avert the
disaster that otherwise might be headed
our way we will all right well professor
thanks very much thank you thank you
very much for inviting me be well
you